three of the greatest offers of all time
were domino's offer some of you guys may
remember this but it was um
delivered to your door in 30 minutes or
it's free
hello everyone and welcome back to
i guess my show so anyways um i guess
you could call a show i don't know
thoughts anyways so um i wanted to make
something so this called the offer is
king
um and that's because the offer is king
so
if you have a good enough offer you
don't have to sell hard you don't have
to have amazing copy or amazing creative
you just get a lot of people to sign up
for your thing
and so if you really think about your
business
most businesses should be founded on a
core offer
that is exceptional like an irresistible
offer that is what's going
to grow the business right and so
what i want to walk you through is uh
three really good offers
uh the three components of those offers
and then seven ways to ethically use
free
so um we're gonna cover a lot of ground
really fast so
um three of the greatest offers of all
time were domino's offer some of you
guys may remember this but it was um
uh delivered to your door in 30 minutes
or it's free
right that's an irresistible offer and
they had [ __ ] pizza
but because of that people wanted to
make the order they didn't have to sell
them on it they saw the offer and when
they were hungry they were like shoot in
30 minutes i can do that
i can have pizza at my door and
sometimes there's almost gamification
it's almost a challenge
that's like well if it's not in 30
minutes i get the pizza free so um
it's it was something that was
incredibly compelling and it was one of
the fundamental uh
keys to their growth and why back in the
days of yellow pages it was
literally an entire section was pizza no
other restaurant had a food category of
pizza everything else is just
restaurants right
so um anyway that was because of that
one
key irresistible offer all right the
next was uh
10 cds for a penny right this was from i
think it was sony way back in the day
now obviously it came with continuity
and so that was kind of like the first
trial offer
um but that offer is one of the single
greatest offers of all time for those
who are old enough to remember it
the third offer uh you may recognize uh
which is
when it absolutely has to get there by
tomorrow morning
and that is fedex so you'll notice the
first two kind of have a pricing
component
fedex does not but it has a really high
value
component to it so i just want to break
down these things into
uh three pieces each offer has
a component of believability right uh
there's a famous
marketer who said uh for every dollar
you give me i'll give you a thousand
dollars back he ran an ad in the paper
and he got zero responses
right that is a crazy offer but it's so
good that it's not believable and
literally no one responded to the ad
right and so one of the things that
makes offers believable is having a
reason why
that you would do this right if you're
like hey i'm you know i'm dropping all
my prices by half off because i uh
all my inventory's going to go bad
people believe that they're like okay
or like i'm overstocked and i got to
make room for you know new
new inventory everything's half off
people believe that it's a good reason
why right
so believability is number one number
two is a high roi offer so basically
um an offer that people deem valuable uh
that can be communicated in a couple of
words like
guarantee you to your door in 30 under
30 minutes that was valuable
for fedex it was at you know delivered
to wherever you need to be
or wherever it needs to go by next
morning that is valuable right
you can give offers but if people don't
find it valuable it's not going to
matter right
and so um the third piece is kind of the
business around it
right and so that's kind of what i want
to cover with free offers because you'll
notice
the penny offer is basically free uh the
domino's pizza offer has a free
component to it and so understanding how
to use free
as a marketer is probably in my opinion
the single most valuable thing
that you can learn how to do it's
learning how to build a better mousetrap
and so
right now i'm working on a book called
acquire
and the subtext is building a better
mousetrap which is just kind of like
how to structure offers in a way that
you can get tons of volume but also make
money on the offers
right and so this is uh you know my
notes for the different ways that you
can use free offers and i think i have
seven on here so i'll walk you through
them pretty quickly
um to just kind of explain them so
the benefit of having free offers is
that you get the highest volume of leads
right number one number two it's it's
typically the lowest cost to acquire
customers so that's number two
and the third is that in my opinion the
key to having massive growth is to
having a free offer right and especially
something that's irresistible
that can spread through word of mouth
that other people can comprehend all
right
so first of the free offers is a free
bribe offer
right so this is where you offer a so
when someone comes in you offer
a program for free as a benefit for
signing up
right so frank kern way back in the day
did a uh he had all of his courses that
he'd ever made so high value offer
probably 12 000 in value he said i'll
give you all of the courses that i've
ever made
absolutely free if you sign up for my
397
a month continuity right my newsletter
or whatever right so that's a free bribe
offer so you can use the word free
brings lots of attention has huge value
in roi
but it was a free with purchase right so
that's kind of the idea like if you buy
this much smaller
thing you get this huge value thing for
free and it's also a really nice price
anchor okay
so that's number one if you're doing a
fitness thing it's like hey um our six
week challenge is a thousand dollars or
you can just sign up to become a member
and get our thousand dollar challenge
for free
and only become a member for 200 a month
right that becomes a really compelling
offer lots of people say yes and you get
people straight into continuity
all right the second is a limited free
offer a limited free offer is let's say
uh this is an a b closed when someone
walks in the door um
obviously the vast majority of people
are seeing this are gym owners so i'm
gonna just make it gym specific
so if someone's coming in you say okay
the free thing let's say uh you sign up
for a 14 day or let's say a 28 day you'd
sen you're coming in for 28 day
promotion
uh the free thing uh has one you know
you could say 28 day trial
they come in it's one day a week of
workouts you have no personalized
nutrition no nutri
no accountability coach right now during
the sales process they'll have already
said they're not motivated they need
help blah blah blah
and so then you upsell right as american
as apple pie a 28-day challenge or
28-day intensive or whatever you want to
call it accelerator
where they uh they pay 199 or 299 or
whatever
for the enhanced version that has three
workouts a week or unlimited workouts
and personalized nutrition and an
accountability coach and
if they don't uh you know lose 10 pounds
in the first 28 days you give them
another 28 days free
right so you have an upsell from an
initial offer that makes it incredibly
compelling
right that's the point so they get all
this volume for free but then you can
still upsell three out of four people
into a paid offer all right so that's
how you use free and you can monetize it
the third way of using free is a free
trial plus penalty so this would be a
down so
it so these can be used in in
conjunction with one another so if
someone uh
doesn't take that that you know the a b
close that i just mentioned
you could say awesome if you're going to
stay then you have to put a card down
because you want to be
held accountable you have to work out
this many times if you miss your
workouts we're going to charge you for
the missed workouts
and you have to attend the you know a
feedback session and a transformation
picture session and a nutrition session
right
if you don't show any of those it's 50
bucks and so they have a huge motivator
to actually consume your product or
service so the likely they convert on
the backend is significantly higher
right that's the point and so that way
at least your trials become
more qualified trials they're more
invested and it's a really easy close
to close someone on on a free trial if
you can't close free trials then
you have other issues okay um the fourth
one is a free with
deposit so this is a classic um the old
six feet challenge that we ran for a
very very very long time was probably
the most
popular fitness offer in the last decade
um was a free six-week challenge
obviously you always have to be
compliant put stipulations for any types
of things things on your advertisements
um states differ etc but that's where if
someone hits a goal they do an
outcome um they can get their money back
or get it credited towards something so
it's like
it's free with a contingency so it's
like you put x dollars down
uh if you do x y and z you can either
get it back or you can get it towards
the program whatever
right that's kind of the pitch there so
it's a free with deposit so free with
stipulations
all right the uh the the fifth uh way of
doing free
is free forever and this is a really
compelling offer so this is where you
have to really know how your mousetrap
works right
so if you have multiple ways of
monetizing a customer i could say for
example i will train you for free
for legitimate free like i will give you
free training straight up your
membership's true forever
right as long as you just do the things
that i tell you to do which
may include buying supplements from us
that's part of the program
now um a good friend of mine owned a
a chain of shadow franchise of uh
weight loss clinics and they made only
like five percent of their revenue on
service and they made
95 of their revenue on supplements and
so people would come in and they'd
essentially give the service away for
free
uh but they were required to use the
supplements as a part of it so that's a
free
100 free but you're you're you're
bolting on a different revenue stream so
that's where you can offer
multiple services and monetize a
different service than the one you're
giving away for free
right um and especially if you have
something that's
uh high margin uh you can give that away
for free if something's high margin and
low value
uh it's an easy thing that you can give
away for free and then give something
else away that's higher perceived value
or make them buy something that's higher
perceived value
people tend to appreciate physical
products more than they appreciate
service or value service
all right so that's kind of a free
forever model which is really
understanding
how you can monetize the second need the
next thing they're gonna need
after the first thing all right the
sixth way is a a free giveaway
uh this is a classic you know you run
you run a uh uh a free giveaway let's
say
meals for a month right i'll pay for all
your food for a month i'll pay for your
whatever
right um and so you get tons of people
are gonna opt in for that and you say
like well we you know we picked one
person
but if you still under the program it's
this and we'll give you a discount since
you you know
signed up or you know sign up to be a
part of it so the thing is is when you
have this
people are still raising their hand to
demonstrate they have a need for the
service
right and so if you have a giveaway
that's perceived as high value
and something that's related to the core
offer that you have you instantly get
tons of very cheap leads that are
qualified for the service
all right um a good friend of mine uh
just started running a 25 000
transformation challenge and he's
getting people to buy
without even doing phone calls um
straight on the page because it's a 25
000
challenge and it's like 300 bucks to
sign up online so people are seeing the
huge
giveaway and they're choosing to
participate
um to have the have the have the chance
to earn that right now obviously
with giveaways and things like that you
always have to make sure you're not
gambling all that kind of stuff
um but i'm just talking big high-level
marketing all right
um the next and probably last one of
these seven
um there's probably more these are just
the ones i thought off on top of my head
um is a free with free with commitment
so not contingency but commitment
so that's where you say uh your first 28
days or your first month is free
um as long as you commit to a nine month
contract or you commit to a whatever
right and so when you do that you can
still market free
um you still you'd have to again put
contingencies in you want to be a
compliant advertiser
um but that way you can still give
people free on the front end it makes
the sale very easy puts a little bit
more the onus on the fulfillment
but if you get the commitment which you
should then you
will be able to convert a very high
percentage of people in the front end
and typically
at higher average contract values
because they're not confronting that
price on the front end
uh it's more like perceived value on the
back end and they're kind of sort of
going to see how it goes right
now that being said during the process
you still need to sell the people even
if you're not closing them so even if
someone has
their caller file and it's planning on
rebuilding you still need to sell them
on staying so just a big mistake that i
see happen all the time
is that when people give trials and
things like that they're not actually
they just sell the trial
rather than selling the continuity
selling someone on trial is just selling
them on trying it
you have to still sell them again even
if they're on you know
auto bill or whatever because the thing
is is you know thirty percent of people
who go through are gonna immediately
call you up and say oh no i didn't mean
to let that go through and then you have
chargebacks and all sorts of crap so
you don't want that make sure they know
they're going to get billed and if it
were me i'd probably only bill the
people that
um i knew had been sold and had kind of
at least verbally agreed to we already
have the contract but at least i know
that they're in
so um those are seven ways
to make free offers to get lots of
people in the door and make irresistible
offers that will ultimately make you
more money so learning how to monetize
free is one of the biggest
tools in your skill set in your toolbox
and if you don't know how to do it
you will be a significant disadvantage
because your competitors will be
and they can acquire more customers at a
cheaper price than you do
and if they can monetize them in the
ways that i just outlined
and you just know the metrics you know
what percentage convert what percentage
stay what the average ticket is and
that's why knowing the math is so
important
but if you know those metrics then you
can mark it with reckless abandon
because you know what your ltv
is and you know that you can win based
on those numbers so
anyways hope that was valuable for you
uh the offer is absolutely king like
if you get the offer right someone
should be able to explain to someone
else in like one sentence
or two sentences what it is that the
offer is
if if you can't explain it like that
then it is not clear enough to a
prospect
and if you get the offer right it will
make you more money than you know what
to do with
all right so anyways uh i hope you guys
have an amazing tuesday uh keep rocking
and rolling and i'll catch you guys soon
like and comment if you found this
valuable so the gods of the internet
will favor this and show it to more
people
alright keeping awesome catch you soon
[Music]
bye
you